we should know that lawmakers have
reconvened on capitol hill after the
chaos there the reports of multiple
explosive devices found around
washington
hard to believe it's real but it is real
our reporter rich edson is following
this story for us he joins us now hey
rich
hey good evening tucker and what law
enforcement officials are telling us
that they found at the very least
three devices around the capital area
that appeared to be
pipe bombs there were these black pipes
and had wires coming out of them it's
something that
the officers investigated bomb squads
were called in
also it was easy to get lost around here
because this was around the time
that you had tens of thousands of people
flooding behind me onto the capitol
complex
many of whom who breached into the
capitol building the mob scene on going
on in there
meanwhile outside you have this bomb
squad response
the new york times is reporting that
there was a pipe bomb that was destroyed
at the republican headquarters now the
rnc is just
right around the capitol complex close
to the house office buildings where much
of this was ongoing
rnc was evacuated that device was
destroyed
also the times is reporting that the dnc
the democratic national committee which
is also nearby
there was a similar mysterious device
found
but there was no confirmation about yet
specifically what that was so while we
had this scene ongoing here
there was a pipe bomb incident you do
have law enforcement who had been
warning about potential incidents
ongoing throughout the capital for days
if not weeks now
and so uh that just another element to
what we saw here today
tucker richardson for us good to see you
thank you